انتقد مالك ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه الخاصه
يفجينه بريكوجين عدم امداد قوه بما تحتاجه
من الذخيره ما يتسبب في مضاعفه الخسائر
بين مقاتليه واتهما
في تصريح له من من وصفهم بمعرقلي الانتصار
بالعمل بشكل مباشر مع العدو
ان الذخائر موجوده لا يمكنني معالجه هذه
المساله رغم كثره علاقات ومعارفي عندما
نصل الى مساله التوقيع على مستندات يهز
الجميع راسه ويقول انت تعلم علاقتكم هناك
ليست بالسهله عليك ان تذهب وتعتذر عندها
يحصل مقاتلوك على الذخيره اليوم يقتل ضعف
مقاتليه فاجنر ومقاتله الوحدات الاخرى
لعدم قدره فاينر على تغطيتهم وهذا بسبب
عدم السماح بتزويدنا بما هو موجود في
المستودعات اولئك الذين يعرقلون انتصار
يعملون بشكل مباشر مع العدو تنضموا
الينا من غرب
لافي ومن خرسون مراسل جزيره حسان مسعود
وايضا من دونياس مراسل جزيره امين دورغامي
عامر ابدا معك مع اخر التطورات الميدانيه
والمستجدات
[موسيقى]
نعم فداء نحن الان على الطريق الواصل بين
سلافيانس ومدينه محمود هذا الطريق الذي
يسمى الطريق الشمالي او ام زيرو 3 خلفي
تماما هذا هو الحاجز الاخير الذي تمكنا من
الوصول اليه ومنعنا من التقدم اكثر قالوا
لنا الجيش الاوكراني قال لنا بان التقدم
اكثر من ذلك خطر على ارواحكم وبالتالي لا
يمكنكم التقدم فقط العربات العسكريه ومن
لديه اذن خاص يمكنه التقدم بعد هذا الحاجز
لماذا هذا الطريق فدا قد تم قطعه عمليا من
جانب قوات فاجنر الان هذا الطريق لا يمكن
الوصول من خلاله الى مدينه مخمود واشرس
المعارك هي تلك التي تدور اصلا في المحور
الشمالي لهذه المدينه طبعا تعلمين ربما
هناك طريقان رئيسيان او خطين سريعان
يؤديان الى مخموت هذا هو الطريق الشمالي
الذي قطع وبقي هناك طريق اخر في الجنوب
يصل بين قسطنطنيفكا ومخمود هذا لم يقطع
لكن استخدامه خطر جدا لدى المعارك تدور
على
[تصفيق]
فقط من الشمال من الشرق لكن في الشرق يوجد
نهر محمود يحجز بين المقايم المتقاتلين
وبالتالي يمنع التقدم كبير للقوات الروسيه
في الجنوب ايضا هناك معارك وهناك تحشيد
ويختلف الوضع كما قالت لنا المصادر عن ما
كان في الايام السابقه حيث تمكنت القوات
الاوكرانيه من دفع القوات الروسيه قليلا
عن الطريق السريع لكن اليوم اخبرونا بان
هناك تكثيف ايضا الهجمات هناك ومحاوله
للتقدم لكن ليس كما هو الوضع في الشمال
ايضا الوضع الانساني داخل هذه المدينه صعب
اليوم تحدث
حاكم مقاطعه دونس وتحدث عن مقتل مدنيين
داخل هذه المدينه وتحديدا في الاحياء
الغربيه
اثره قصف مدفعي وصاروخي روسي على هذه
الاحياء طبعا نشير هنا الى ان هذه المدينه
التي كان يسكنها تقريبا 70000 انسان الان
هناك فقط ثلاثه الاف انسان رفضوا مغادره
هذه المدينه واضح رب ما فدى ان هناك
استماته من كلا الطرفين ان صح استخدام هذا
التعبير القوات الروسيه تريد ان تسيطر على
هذه المدينه لتحقق نصرا معنويا قبل الرابع
والعشرين وايضا في المقابل القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تريد ان تمنح هذا النصر
وبالتالي هذا يفسر ربما الاستفاده
الاوكرانيه في الدفاع عن هذه المدينه
[موسيقى]